what happens with the postmodernist as
they say oh there's an infinite number
of interpretations and then the human
part of them goes okay well what am I
supposed to do next then since there's
an infinite number of choices and the
postmodernist says well my theory can't
account for that and then they say well
back to Marxism and so that's why I
think there's this unholy alliance
between the post modernists and the
neo-marxists is because post-modernism
is a is a dead end from the perspective
of applicable wisdom it leaves you
bereft and nihilistic and that's not
good because people can't exist without
a purpose and so they sneak the Marxism
through the back door and and jump into
this power landscape for the reasons
that we discussed earlier you really
think that it's because of an infinite
number of possibilities interpretating
things because I've always felt that it
was really just a response to capitalism
they feel that capitalism is a very
negative aspect of our culture and
society and that there's got to be some
sort of an alternative Marxism is a
clearly defined alternative that other
people have subscribed to in the past
you could point to it it's a structure
that's already already set up and it's
romanticized and I think they adopt it
for that reason because it has a
socialist aspects attached to it and
they looked at socialism as it's some
sort of a thing that regards equality
and you know it's some sort of an
egalitarian approach well it's okay so
we'd have to take two things apart we'd
have to take Marxism slouch neo-marxist
Marxism and post-modernism apart so we
could do that historically and I would
say that although there is a reason for
post-modernism which is the reason we
just discussed that the the landscape
the infinite landscape of interpretation
problem it's a real problem if you look
at it historically post-modernism
actually grew out of Marxism and so what
what happened is that the Marxists laid
out their their their theory about the
human social environment being composed
of a power struggle between the
privileged and the underprivileged right
the rich and the poor and in its initial
phases and that's a story that's
partially true and it's got a lot of
motive power like the motive power is
the romantic motive power that you just
described I get to be on the side of the
oppressed I get to be a war or for
what's right
there's the resentment element which is
that son-of-a-bitch has more than me so
let's cut them off at the knees which
manifested itself brutally in the Soviet
Union and then there's the ideological
totality issue which gives people a
sense of security that took a vicious
hit by the late 1960s because the
murderous nosov Marxism had been clearly
laid out as a doctrine and that opened
the door to this move by by mostly
French intellectuals to to develop the
postmodern philosophy which has these
advantages which we described but but
also to use that as a screening tactic
for allowing Marxism to transform into
identity politics and so it like it's
hard to disentangle all the motivations
that are going on in there but there's
something about it that's that's truly
intellectually pathological because you
don't get to be a postmodernist and a
Marxist you actually technically cannot
be both of those things at the same time
and the fact that most people are both
of those things at the same time raises
the specter of just exactly what their
motivation is and then I would say it's
this resentment driven anti capitalism
there's reasons to criticize capitalism
obviously but it's this underground
resentment driven anti capitalism that I
think is one of the fundamental
motivators